metro is really stressing safety  following the death of two children in  pool drowning incidents over the weekend  now to avoid another tragedy this summer  officials want to remind you of the  three p's patrol designated adult to  supervise kids in the water at all times  and protect you can do that by  installing fencing door alarms locks or  other safety measures also you want to  make sure you prepare make your child  make sure your child is enrolled in  swimming lessons take cpr classes have a  plan in place to call 9-1-1 in the event  of an emergency and if you have a party  hire a lifeguard the guests will not be  watching the pool they'll be enjoying  the party hire a lifeguard